bang bang a annoncé pagnol qui n'a pas
appris à nager avec ma gueule à rester
seule demande et demi panaché sur le
charles charles jani
[Musique]
raconter surtout cochon c'est quoi c'est
là sans billet qui croise un cochon et
les abats vieux et la chimio constat pas
à mesure que tu attendais et si tu m'a
réconcilié avec la chanson française
oui c'est pas un de mes moindre mérite
je reviendrai à montréal pendant un
grand boeing bleu de bain
je vais m'en veux revoir l'hiver et 7,3
rebonds rien aux gens du quartier site
avait voyagé allant vers des rivages
côtiers quartier participent aujourd'hui
andré montréal bank of montreal avant
que kyoto coup mais montréal est un
petit quartier quartier où jack mais
j'adore charlebois château sur le web
c'était mon pays ce n'est pas un pays
comme entre les vignes où c'est jean
vigneau ça c'était comment bailly ce
n'est pas un pays c'est bon
enfin ça dépend des chemins cet adage
simplement sur sa gamme indiqué avant la
neige mari mon père l'a fait quand il
m'attend à présent de sa tata j'ai
choisi comme si ce moment par le patron
c'est ma maison
venus n s'il voulait j'ai découvert à
jour un album si tu vas voir 14 15 ans
l'album s'appelle la francofête
et ça a été enregistré dans les plaines
d'abraham avec québec et il y avait non
soi que l'album s'appelle j'ai vu le
loup le renard le lion voix mais c'est
fait gilles vigneault félix leclerc
charlebois en concert la plus grande
fête francophone du québec saaq avait
quatre cent mille personnes et tous les
trois lâchers comme une fontaine et il
faisait doux mais méchant je ne vais pas
répéter depuis dix ans c'est pas un
problème pour la chanteuse souliers ont
beaucoup voyagé
[Applaudissements]
je travaille sur mes souvenirs et des
bons c'est sa guise
peut-être un petit bonhomme tout genre à
marseille ils étaient tous temple tout
le barda français quand ils ces
militants puis j'ai eu il s'est mise à
crier pluton qui s'est mise à crier
monsieur emporté paul serait bel et bon
mais vraiment oublié comment ne pas
visiter des zones inondées goût de
recommencer
félix leclerc qui n'est pas fort je
tiens les fait courir de fès nouvelle
france m contre bordeaux je cours de jeu
gunn découvrons toyer bois
le plaisir yvelines
donc content de mon corps de fonds
faisant dire ton que dans mon coeur est
double
dans son
beaucoup
on songe ou con
après ramallah
et devinez ce qu'il faut pas qu'on voit
son regard il est perdu il est ailleurs
suzanne orange et dans un verre de
tennessee vous a aidé plus là encore il
s'en fout le dieu de la guitare et chant
foulée
[Musique]
et l'autre joue une demi heure trois
quart d'heure laissant foule est plus là
il ailleurs haut débit piloté les
embêter dans des reer doute rien et
loups sont entrés dans paris soit par
ici ça part en vrille d'égout sont
entrés dans paris
sellerie charmante elle vit
et l'eau sont entrés dans paris par izia
ni reggiani
jonas après les vacances
d'abord la moindre partie un peu naïve
jarry dans la boîte de jazz
histoire d'oublier un public ou de ma
vie les gars de me regarder berbère
c'est pas un habitué
sûrement pas l'amour le désir lancastre
s'installe les professionnels
commandement et c'est moi qui
s'interpellent et gus koné charlie
mingus part que je connais par coeur et
puisse le nom de davis aussi je connais
aussi j'aime tous les succès de duke
ellington tous les standards oscar
peterson
lionel hampton manager sound chaudhary
zanuck évoqué blanc blanc blanc je
voulais te dire
que je t'attends tu entends tu savais
comme je t'attends
je t'attends je t'attends tout le temps
ce soir demain n'importe quand comme
quelqu'un qui n'a pas pas vous apprendre
que ben je fais away je pense que cet
homme que sera ma vie mais bon de tous
ces gens way qui m'a dit faire
maintenant a créé tout est fini j'aime
pas mais quand ce n'est pas moi aussi je
sais pas ce qu'ils sont devenus vieux
con alors une chanson française d'une
chanson française attac est donc je sais
si je serai ce héros mais mon coeur est
tranquille
et les vies c'est que la bourse serait
de bleu pour ce qu un miséreux
seul qu'un malheureux cherche encore et
encore
bien qu ils ont tout brûlé
mal encore
les verts sont écartelés pour atteindre
l'inaccessible étoile
attend il
c'est mérité c'est un guy je suis comme
ça je vais le laisser à ce qu'on va
faire c'est que j'ai laissé ça c'est
andouillettes est énorme
bynum une andouillette sans frites c'est
un peu comme comment dire comme le bain
moussant ses nouveaux seins et quoi
c'est ça pas grand intérêt
bon je vais me fâcher avec tout le monde
c'est pas grave la vie ressemblait
rigide en avant ce n'est pas un apprenti
mais c'est tellement vagabond je suis le
vagabond le patient de bonheur je n'ai
que les chansons ramener très jeune mais
que si vous parlez
on m'appelle romane des mois j'ai
demandé pas le méchant dans les bois et
je change ma joie par dessus les toits
oui je voulais faire vivre des premiers
amours qui me donnaient rendez vous sur
le chesnay et se laisser embrasser sur
la joue je ne voudrais pas faire le
chemin de la baisse pourtant j'ai payé
cher pour une ivresse heureuse d'art et
un dépôt de l'ombre d'une fille en fleur
on oublie le temps
non mais j'espère que tu n'as rien
contre les gens de différents hélène si
j'étais cuit attention mesdames et
messieurs dans un instant
sap a commencé installez vous dans votre
fauteuil bien gentiment les plans 4.20
partait tous les projecteurs vont
s'allumer et tous les acteurs vont
s'animer en même temps les filles nous
avons matin
et bla de chansons comme le soleil
jalons près dans votre maison
notre pari bras
notre veille beau si vous le voulez
c'est de bon coeur que nous partageons
tous on dirait que c'est jane de venir
avec nous
on dirait que ça dégèle de marcher dans
la boue ont ils à jets de divers avec
nous j'allais le long des rues comme un
enfant perdu
j'avais faim j'avais froid
à toi paris qui m'a pris dans ses bras
à l'avenir
debbie la chanson merde mais comme les
rois mages en galilée
suivez des yeux l'étoile du berger ou tu
vibres et où tu iras j'irai fidèles
comme une ombre
jusqu'à destination plaise au ciel que
s'ouvre mes fenêtres le matin au bord
d'un étang bleus plaise au ciel que rien
ne nous arrête dans ce monde aventure
comme les rois mages en galilée regarde
d'abord il est déjà 10 ans voit son
roman la tati t'emporter du temps dans
mon cas parmi ces milliers de gens c'est
un moment viticole
pour marcher dans la forêt où on
trouverait plus dans mal d'aller se
coucher seul dans les jeunes et de la
dire que c'est une chose qu'on ne voit
jamais chaque fois c'est pareil c'est
quand on est derrière avec un wii puis
quand on travaille depuis quand le ciel
est bon il fait pour voisin dégueulasse
ils font vivre un pont du de l'entrée on
s'est arrêté sur mes 10 mois ce moment
tu apprécies tu m'a dit je vais partir
et puis tu es parti chercher et où le
repos - j'ai vécu comme un rebond raison
qu'une autre n'est venue n'a remonté ma
vie là où tu vas tu trouveras j'étais
sur la bête et monkey race et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux